dans 3 2
action génial c'était
[Musique]
génial tout le monde sauf lui je l'ai
pas validé tu le sais très bien tu es
littéralement la dernière personne sur
terre que je v de voir je suis à deux
doigs de te gifler là ça me dé mange je
Seris pas contre l'idée dans un
environnement moins
dangereux tu t'es volatilisé pas un coup
de fil pas un
message c'est pas que j'ai pas voulu
m'excuser justifie pas si tu juste un
flirt alors comment tu vas ah les
cascadeurs je déteste vos conneries de
pous en
l'air je suis la réal je vais le mettre
en feu toi tu es un cascadeur il faut
qu'on reste super prof
professionnel c'est mon surnom ah oua je
croyais que c'était
danger c'était comment
boss carrément un fling avec les doigts
je l'ai rangé ça y est fa comme si
tuavais rien
vu Tom
rider la plus grande star de film
d'action du monde a disparu il faut que
tu le retrouves sinon le film de jod est
fichu pourquoi moi parce que tu es
cascadeur personne ne va te rebarquer
c'est ton boulot pas mal ah bah un peu
si tu retrouves rider tu sauves le film
de J tu récupères l'amour de ta vie je
suis pas le héros seulement la doublure
non pas
aujourd'hui Tom on a besoin de toi sur
le tournage mon
[Musique]
pote
oh la vache un cadavre dans la glace il
était méga mort gale mort de chez
mort il s'est mis à fréquenter des gens
vraiment très
louches j'ai pas eu le choix j'étais
obligé de passer en BL tu
vois ils ont essayé de me
tuer il faisit pas semblant tu peux le
faire tu peux le faire ça va pas le
faire c'est trop dangereux
il y a des
escaliers blessé qu'est-ce qu'il y a tu
as vraiment une tte
magnif quand tu tombes direct j tu
pourrais aller pour la personne que tu
es je te qu sera termin cont
les tuis qu tu aller te poser sur une
plage boire des Margarita épicé et faire
les mauvais choix
[Musique]
oui